how many Edison's does it take to screw
in a light bulb
how many who cares he stole the idea and
doesn't deserve his own joke comedy easy
right apparently [ __ ] so how many
difficult thing to talk about because it
happens to be so subjective there is not
one joke so every single person will
laugh I can guess and something that
many people might find downright
freaking hilarious may make you question
if you're just a cynical Cunnings off
the ability to find any kind of humor in
this world which are definitely [ __ ]
are so I say cautiously that is very
rare that actually find a comedy anime
that I like with only a select handful
ever making me audibly laugh out loud
looks are a vital part of being a
delinquent amateurs should try bleaching
their hair blond to look tough be
careful if the chemicals are too strong
your hair will turn white and you'll
look like a [ __ ] damage happens because
my sense of humor doesn't resonates with
looking over the top and almost
slapstick style jokes I've seen a lot of
gag anime my main problem is that most
jokes Center on one specific punch line
or guys now while they can't Rudy head
culminating in some of my favorite
moments and animate most of the time
they just really miss or get old really
really fast so one kind of fever started
to rise in popularity and I heard about
the appeal of its comedy it still didn't
look like something I would find funny
and when I eventually sat down and
watched it for the most part I was right
then make me laugh that much and yet I
enjoyed the hell out of it i marathon
the entire first season in one fitting
corner Suba isn't nearly the funniest
anime of seemed for me at least I never
audibly laughed too hard and I'm not
really a big enough fan of the fantasy
RPG setting to care about lots of the
parody aspects of it yet despite all
this it managed to remain as one of my
most consistently entertaining comedies
come out of anime I may not have last
hard but I enjoyed it a lot watching the
episodes will I can see me popcorn for
me and I personally can't think of many
classic characters that I'm as attached
to as these one the group are so
endearing that I could spend hours just
watching their antics on screen and I
did the reason for this is that I
actually see some of the same principles
I've used when writing my own parodies
in the past so that I'm claiming to be a
professional comedian we'll get right to
a source but a lot of what makes Curtis
fever so appealing at its core is the
same thing I see that went into a verb
which vbz a bridge from team four star
and a lot of sitcoms you watch which I
don't see very often in anime it's
something that even you can take on and
try yourself if you ever want to attempt
something like this
having some random bozo breakdown the
appeal by researching through the
science of comedy funding the little
intricacies to telling the perfect stick
joke I thought it would be interesting
to analyze it from a perspective from
someone who's attempted to write
different styles of company myself you
know the same guy who's giving you such
masterpieces out in regions yeah now
from an outsider perspective it may be
hard to see the appeal of courtesy with
comedy in just the way the community
treats it yes some kind of parody of the
fancy world setting some chick who's
fallen to the bait of Schrodinger's cats
with her [ __ ] pants a main guy seems
like a simple dick and I go everyone
seems to be [ __ ] obsessed with thanks
to something about her and some big
juicy explosion magic so what makes is
so popular
to its credit there are a lot of things
kind of see what does right to make it
funny and I've been mentioned quite lost
before the actual execution of most
shows are pretty top-notch the comedic
timing is great it routinely subvert our
expectations to parody the fancy and RPG
genre pretty well the animation
perfectly accentuates any joke and you
can tell how much fun the voice actors
are having by the way they deliver their
lines being absolutely spot-on but I'm
not here to talk about any of that as
personally I don't think there's
anything that ruins the jokes faster
than explaining it and breaking down its
execution know what I'm here to do is
break down what makes the comedy in the
show tick at its core it's the basic
thing any of you can take into your own
when writing your own skits or comedy
and it's all revolves around the cast of
characters yes these calls for members
of the [ __ ] are [ __ ] the weirdo and
the meme is what makes this show so
endearing and it's the core for pretty
much all the comedy in this series but
why is that well to me what makes the
show continually entertaining it's just
seen the cast interact with each other
as different things arise in the world
they are in there's no one specific joke
but it's their dynamic and chemistry
that carries the comedy I'm by
understanding this dynamic and how to
get there is a technique even you can
use when you're trying to parody
something a simple way to approach this
is to take a well-known character trait
and completely flipping them on its head
this is what I personally did with Gendo
from Ava bridge turning one of the most
sneaky manipulative ass polish
characters in a super serious show and
making a move down like idiot or
alternatively you can take the
well-known traits and crank them up so
far that it becomes ridiculous this is
something quite clearly seen in Team
four stars helping a bridge as they took
the badass immortal alley card and
cranked up his confidence so much but he
no longer gives a [ __ ] about anything
we'll take
anything seriously which works for his
character because why would an opium
mortal vampire fill any threats but it
also gives opportunity for some
entertaining character interaction stop
I need to talk to you about some
important guests coming today
No and like that you've lost me it
sounds very simple but it is highly
effective and you can even see you can
play with this lovable cars of idiots
how do we parody the edgy powerful
paragon of Justice protagonists of so
many Clancy World shows you flip it on
his head and make cousin wonder cynical
every man with no powers whatsoever what
about a physical cinder a valley and I
can keep mage the cinder egg goes so far
off the deep end she becomes a
self-centered [ __ ] the valiant knight
becomes so devoted to protecting others
is reaching to the point of masochism
and the major so obsessed with getting
play of the game she only waits for that
one perfect alt the entire match and
those nothing else
the important thing is you need a core
cast of characters that work well with
each other and have genuine chemistry
we've traced our ring to like the
elements of whatever traits you are
trying to parody in the first place
but you don't do this by thinking of
your characters as just a vessel to tell
jokes but as actual characters so for
any outsider looking into the series it
may seem like the explosions and the
masochism I just gimmicky means use for
the butt of jokes but there is so much
more to the cast than that there is a
balance to the four of them you're so
like these weirdos were made for each
other and that's the dynamic you should
strive for when you're plotting the
basic outline to your core characters
they feel like a group of friends that
have this love/hate relationship with
each other giving up the same kind of
banter their unity was a tight-knit
group and it's these little interaction
so make it slow down entertaining so you
see once you have this baseline set up
the rest is easy because you already
have the recipe for humor scenarios by
simply having these characters be
together
you don't write jokes you write
characters and in doing so the
punchlines and jokes will come naturally
after their basic interactions the real
trick is to put them in interesting
scenarios where they're dynamic will be
highlighted for the greatest comedic
effect and while you can introduce more
characters to change up this dynamic
every so often it will always go back to
be poor or for what happened if you
don't approach you like this is that you
get characters done a basically
punchline machine they exist for no
purpose than to throw in a punch line
with joke I'm all this can work for a
time you've run the risk of it getting
old incredibly fast which is why I feel
the weakest part of this show by five
when we try to make the punch line
darkness was overly masochistic behavior
it's predictable it's cheap and so
character and it forces the viewer to
watch a girl essentially just get off on
screen
I'm sorry was I talking about negatives
let me let me delete that last line
aside from this though colony is one of
the best examples I can think of in
anime of the character driven comedy and
it's for this reason that someone like
me doesn't even have to find the jokes
that funny to be continually entertained
as watching them almost gives you the
same feel-good emotions of Tang yella -
close friends but his way gets are
attach them to the more we watch the
more inclusive we feel - their
relationship it's like we are the first
person in their group laughing along
with the antics rolling our eyes when
someone does something stupid and caring
in those brief moments when they break
out their mold it's why they are so
lovable as a group why we get so
attached to them and that I feel is the
real strength of this show because a lot
of people will label this as a simple
parity stuff I animate when I think it
actually has more in common with a
sitcom see the basic structure around
sitcoms is following a group of
characters as they go about their lives
dealing with different situations as
they arise
aka a situation comedy and while that
can be progression in character and plot
it is normally at the minimal or very
slow pace drags over many seasons as the
main selling point in each episode is
watching these characters tackle
different situation connoisseur has
these elements was the only difference
being that the situation error and
happen to be revolving around a fantasy
world with RPG trace it isn't so much
for the show is trying to make jokes
paradeen these elements it's more that
we have to be watching a very
entertaining group of individuals as
they encounter and tackle these elements
but by approaching it like this you
actually shows that you have a deeper
understanding of the things you are
trying to parody rather than just merely
referencing it this is a live show like
The Big Bang Theory can be affected as
it is by so many especially in nerd
culture it attempts to parody employed
funded nerds by playing to they're
grossly inaccurate stereotypes and
things like throwing in the odd
references shows any kind of
understanding of the culture I mean can
you imagine and courtesy which I this
approach with a fantasy world setting
all right then it's settled we'll save
this sword out online world with a ratio
and fired no game no life depth ornament
on the log horizon
well that will be easy since darkness
fit Oliver steps levelling up her breast
side I'm sorry why you talking like this
I mean look at me I'm Carrie so Jesus
couldn't God summer having settled this
keep in mind this is by no means the
only way to write comedy what I
presented it was just one way to
approach it as many and there is no one
right way to make something funny from
my research this kind of approach is
good for a long-running stereo live show
as we get attached to the characters
over time and while I appreciate well
thought-out character driven comedies I
can also find very trashy degenerate
toilet humor hilarious food you know if
done right there is no exact science to
this but for what it's worth whether it
be for so talked about or for something
I can cover I can definitely see why I
couldn't see where it's getting the
attention that it is the characters I
love for and it gives off this unique
charm only few comedy anime have ever
been able to achieve that even if you
didn't find it stop busting ly funny
there may still be something for you
here and hopefully you learn something
basic about comedy writing in this video
but remember if all else fails you can
give up on clever writing and fallback
the one thing you can always rely on
[Music]
chose your meal hey guys hope you
enjoyed the video thank you very much -
Patrick Madson Thrones melt Li what ambi
Fujiyama un Fang and everyone else and
peace from helping support me for this
month I'm making this video possible
if you want to see more of my stuff then
click on my videos here and here and you
can also find me on Twitter Facebook and
switch in the links below anyway that's
it for me no updates this time and I
will see you all next time
[Music]